Next we will look at how the replacement
policy for the cache, which chooses,
if you remember, which block to
kick out when we need more room,
interacts with the hit
time of the cache.
A simple replacement policy,
such as random,
which randomly picks the block to
replace among those that are in the set,
has nothing to update on a cache hit.
When we have a cache hit,
we don't have to do anything in
order to be later able to do random.
When we have a miss, that's when
we start implementing our policy
by randomly selecting
a block to kick out.
This results in faster hits, because
there is nothing we need to do for
the replacement policy when we
have a hit, and that's nice.
However the random policy is not very
good for miss rate, because we often
kick out blocks that we will very soon
need to use and we don't like that.
In contrast, least recently used or LRU
results in a lower miss rate, which we
like but we have to run every cache hit
update potentially a lot of counters.
Even if we don't update them
we have to look at them.
So there is a lot of activity on
every cache hit that results from
leaving the state that we'll late use
to select the block we will kick up and
this spends a lot of power and
also results in slower hits.
To illustrate what happens on a cache
hit using LRU, let's look at a four-way
set associative cache whose counters
are currently zero, one, two, and three.
If the processor accesses
this one here and has a hit.
The new values of the counters are going
to be this one becomes the most
recently used And all of the other
counters get decremented.
As you can see, all the counters have
changed and this happens on a cache hit.
So a cache hit can result in
updating up to n counters,
where n is our associativity.
Let's look at what happens when one
of the more recently used blocks
is accessed.
Let's say we access not the most
recent used but the next one.
In that case this becomes
the most recent used block.
The counters that are larger
than this one get decremented so
this becomes two and
the smaller than this stay the same.
So we get this.
So only two counters have changed now.
But note that even though we have
only changed two counters, we had to
actually check for each counter
whether it's lower than this or not.
So even when we access the most
recently used block, and
the counters don't change at all
because this becomes three and
counters larger than it get decremented,
but
there is nothing larger and this,
lower than it stayed the same.
We still, had to determine that
this is the highest counter anyway,
so that we don't decrement anything or
we had to actually check for
each of these counters,
whether it's lower.
So, one way or the other, even for
a hit to the most recently used blog,
we have to do something and that again
slows down the hits and spends power.
So what we want is a replacement policy
that retains the miss
rate very close to LRU.
Meaning we want to smartly
replace the blocks so
that we can cut the block that
is unlikely to be used soon.
Or the least likely to be its own, but
we want to do less activity
on cache hits to do that.